بعد اكثر من ثلاث سنوات انتهت حاله
الطوارئ الصحيه العامه لجائحه كورونا بفضل
اللقاحات والاختبارات والعلاجات واضحى
العالم وفي وضع افضل بكثير والوفيات بسبب
المرض في ادنى مستوى لها منذ عام 2020 وفي
محاوله لابراز المدى الحقيقي للجائحه قالت
منظمه الصحه العالميه في تقرير الى
الوفيات الناجمه عن فيروس كورونا سلبت
سكان العالم ملايين من سنوات الحياه
اكبر نتيجه نبلغ عنها لاول مره هي ان
تاثير فيروس كوفيد ادى الى خساره هائله
لما يقرب من 300 مليون سنه من الحياه
المفقوده على مستوى العالم وهذا يعني
فقدان نحو 22 عاما من الحياه مقابل كل
وفاه اضافيه
جاءت هذه التقديرات في تقرير الاحصاءات
الصحيه العالميه السنوي الذي تنشره
المنظمه وسلط التقرير الضوء على وجود
تفاوتات كبيره في توزيع الاصابات بالفيروس
والوفيات الناجمه عنه بين دول العالم
وقدرتها المنظمه بنحو 20 مليون فضلا عن
توزيع اللقاحات كما حضرت منظمه الصحه
العالميه من ان الجائحه ادت الى تغيير
اتجاهات العديد من المؤشرات المتعلقه
بالصحه بعد ان شهدت تحسنا على مدى سنوات
واضافت ان كورونا كان لها اثر سلبي على
كفاح العالم ضد امراض اخرى معديه حيث
تعطلت خدمات التطعيم والخدمات الصحيه لكن
التحدي في السنوات القليله المقبله لا
يكمل فقط في الامراض المعديه
وقد نبهت منظمه الصحه العالميه الى العبء
المتزايد للامراض غير المعديه وخاصه امراض
القلب والاوعيه الدمويه والسرطان وامراض
الجهاز التنفسي المزمنه والسكري
وتوقعت المنظمه ان تتسبب هذه بنحو سته
وثمانين في المئه من 90 مليون حاله وفاه
سنويا بحلول منتصف القرن ولاول مره اشارت
تقرير صحه العلميه الى تاثير تغير المناخ
على الصحه البشريه
ودعا الى مواجهه هذا الخطر الوجودي على
صحه الانسان وقالت المنظمه ان نتائج
التقرير اظهرت الحاجه الى زياده كبيره في
الاستثمارات في الصحه
لتحسين حياه الناس وجعل العالم اكثر
استعدادا وامانا